bienvenue vous êtes sur envergure
podcast et site internet spécialiste
dans le scooting basketball et donc
notre événement c'est la draft NBA 2023
pour vous préparer on prend les
candidats un par un et on vous donne
l'essentiel sur chacun voici donc
l'essentiel sur Maxwell Lewis
[Musique]
Maxwell Lewis joueur de paperdin en NCA
paper dying pour ce qui la veulent à
l'anglaise née le 27 juillet 2002 il
aura donc encore 20 ans le soir de la
draft mais bientôt 21 2 m 01 82 kg voilà
ce qu'on peut retrouver sur sa fiche sur
notre site
28e dans notre big board pour le moment
au moment où on enregistre ça peut
bouger ensuite 27ème chez ispienne 39e
chez CBS donc un joueur qui est projeté
en fin de premier début de seconde tour
plutôt un ailier et pour en parler
Hugues et Ju présent vous deux
présents
de parler de Maxwell Maxwell on va
commencer par sa biographie et sa
biographie c'est Hugues qui s'en occupe
qui est-il ce monsieur
c'est un mec qui fait le café comme ça
c'est fait pour tout le monde
je suis là pour les calembours
toute ma vie maintenant
c'est un
garçon qui comme on dit qui veut être
professionnel de basket depuis très
longtemps c'est un gars qui se voit être
un joueur de NBA c'est un garçon qui a
grandi dans une famille où le sport
n'est pas forcément hyper mis en avant
il a pas de de parents professionnel il
a pas de comment dire de frère et sœur
qui ont performé même au niveau
universitaire dans pas mal de sport
c'est un garçon qui a hésité à prendre
une offre professionnelle Dilling
overtime élite ou NBA voilà il a hésité
là dessus et puis finalement il a décidé
de laine parce que on avait un coach qui
s'occupait à l'époque du recrutement à
washing et qui avait envoyé des mecs
comme marque iPhone à la draft NBA donc
voilà ça a été pour lui quelque chose de
vraiment décisif et puis pour vous quand
même vous citer pour que vous
connaissiez mieux le garçon sa
biographie sur le site 1 de Paypal dye
on peut apprendre que Maxwell Lewis à
tort joué à Touquet sont son athlète
préférée c'est Kobe Bryant et la paper
dye nous dit Kobe Bryant est un jour
professionnel de basketball et je pense
que c'est tout le monde ne le sait pas
et oui c'est important de le notifier et
puis sa série préférée de tous les temps
c'est squid game il adore le poulet et
les gaufres excusez-moi et son truc
préféré dans le basket et vous allez
voir que c'est un un haikyu du jeu c'est
un mec vraiment dans le dans le détail
son truc préféré dans le basket c'est
entendre la foule crier son nom quand il
met un dunk voilà et oui c'est un homme
qui vit pour les plaisirs simples en
fait c'est ça c'est un kiffeur tout
simplement
et je pense que ça va être un fil
directeur
de ce profil
profil de cet essentiel donc paper Dyne
c'est pas une grosse fac juge j'aimerais
que tu nous situes Pepper dyn sur la
carte des États-Unis
c'est la Malibu très très petite commune
alsacente à Los Angeles très sympa donc
qui faire toujours le même qu'elle a des
buts tranquille et donc quel rôle il
avait dans cette équipe pour redevenir
un peu plus sérieux et je précise j'ai
oublié de le dire dans ma présentation
axol Lewis c'est quand même un gars qui
a commencé à buzzer un peu avant la
draft de l'année dernière par certains
certains hipster du NBA du NBA draft
Twitter
et qui cette année et petit à petit
monté dans les rankings en milieu de
saison certains l'ont envoyé même
loterie et il est un peu redescendu pour
se trouver aujourd'hui vers la fin du
premier tour je t'en prie je pour pour
la présentation de celui qui porte le 24
donc quel rôle pour Maxwell Lewis dans
cette équipe de paper Dyne
il est là pour se correr en fait en tout
cas c'est ce qui fait le plus c'est un
scorer
comment on dit aux trois niveaux il a
une répartition de de tir très simple en
fait 35% près du cirque 32%
en jumper et 33%
à 3 donc voilà on continue dans le
plaisir il teste tout
c'est un joueur essentiellement de je
trouve de série en fait
voilà autour de lui ça
comment dire il y a pas un jeu très très
développé donc il attend son tour et
puis quand il sent que ça commence à
rentrer il va prendre beaucoup beaucoup
de choses et
voilà pour parler sérieusement c'est sa
force c'est le shoot il a notamment le
shoot à 3
et autour de lui juste pour pour il a
fait deux années à paper Dyne
en première année il était plus quand
même cantonné un rôle de shooter et il
sortait du banc c'était pas la même que
cette année quand même alors c'était en
fait il a fait des allers-retours sur le
banc l'année dernière il a commencé sur
le banc il a été titulaire comme tu
disais ça commence à bruisser autour de
lui quand il y a eu le match contre
Gonzaga où il a fait quelques
interceptions et il a dû entendre la
foule de créer son nom parce qu'il a mis
quelques dunks qui est tourné sur
Twitter à l'époque
et puis après il est revenu sur le banc
alors ça montre je pense un petit peu
les limites on en parlera plus tard de
ce joueur quoi mais effectivement gros
taux d'usage ce que tu disais 31%
l'année dernière 28% cette année c'est
des taux d'usage qui sont pas courants
pour des joueurs qui sont plus éliés
puisque ils montaient pas la balle non
plus Maxo Lewis
et alors
il driven kick pas mal quand même et de
quelle manière il se correspond on le
fait tourner autour des écrans juste on
lui donne la balle on lui pose un pic et
on lui dit démerde-toi c'est quoi les
systèmes ça à quoi ça ressemble à quoi
système c'est un bien grand mot je pense
c'est vraiment dur à regarder
il a il bouge pas trop on lui donne la
balle il y a des pics il fait surtout
beaucoup de pièces dribbles et pas
mauvais dans les dans les dribbles dans
les petits espaces
et OK
ok donc tu l'a esquissé mais pour
l'essentiel effectivement nous on aime
bien donner la porte d'entrée voilà
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui peut le
faire rentrer dans la dans la NBA
qu'est-ce qui peut le faire drafter quel
argument il y a écrit tout en haut du
paperboard de l'équipe qui va le drafter
Hugues à ton avis est-ce que c'est le
shoot comme l'a dit Julien
ouais c'est le shoot mais surtout son
shot making parce que on va pas
forcément le temps de Maxwell Lewis en
tout cas si tu veux l'acheter de prendre
du catch and shoot dans le corner c'est
pas ça ça force et pas ce qu'il aime
c'est un mec qui a été très bon pour ce
créer son propre tire se créer des
espaces la moitié d'ailleurs de ces
trois points son prix en pull up un Ford
step back
c'est un joueur qui a une main dominante
sa main droite et qu'on l'oriente côté
main gauche est beaucoup plus compliqué
mais voilà on tu espères si tu l'achètes
et c'est peut-être pour ça aussi qu'il y
a un côté très ambivalent avec des gens
qui l'avaient très haut et puis des gens
qui n'y croient pas du tout c'est que si
tu l'achètes c'est que tu espères qu'ils
puissent créer du jeu au moins
individuellement être un comme Julien
l'a dit un pyromane scorer en série un
microser comme il s'appelle ça et pas
que un gars
en fin de système ou alors un gars en
fin de système qui sort de situation
compliquées aussi
ça veut pas dire qu'il aura forcément ce
rôle mais on a vu des joueurs qui
savaient créer pour eux-mêmes en NCIS
ensuite devenir des joueurs de catch and
shoot et juste le fait qu'il sache créer
pour eux-mêmes c'est le petit truc tac
le petit truc supplémentaire qui fait
qu'ils vont peut-être avoir une utilité
sur une série de playoffs et je pense
alors lui sensi by S ça fond mais je
pense à l'eau ni Walker
qui
savait créer en NCA à qui on n'a pas
trop demander ça chez les Spurs si je ne
m'abuse et qui s'est retrouvé à scorer
lors des du match 4 des Lakers face aux
Warriors pour compléter ce que tu disais
Hugues
au cercle et sur ces midrange également
on a un joueur qui se crée beaucoup
s'étire comme le décrivait Julien
d'ailleurs seulement 38% 39% de ces
tentatives sont biennes de ces de ces
paniers marqués pardon au Cercle
viennent d'une patte décisive et
seulement 22% de ces paniers marqués à
distance au cercle est quand même à 61%
et à mes distances à 39 ce qui est pas
si mal pour un joueur qui se crée ça
paraît ça paraît basse pas très efficace
mais c'est pas si mal
Hugues tu vas ajouter un truc pour
compléter sur l'attaque de cercle en
fait
il y a une comment dire il y va pas si
souvent il y a une bonne efficacité et
puisque j'aime bien c'est qu'il y a un
bon fuseau wait c'est un joueur qui
va générer beaucoup de fautes qui va
générer beaucoup de lancer franc et ça
s'explique par sa capacité à utiliser sa
belle longueur de bras de mettre 8 dans
vergure et il a il est très bon pour
comment dire pour allonger et rétrécir
ses bras côté gogo gadget très délire et
il va réussir à trouver des bons angles
et faire des fautes parce qu'il a pas
réussi dans dans comment dire dans son
développement à prendre de la masse
c'est un garçon quand il arrive en
université il dit en interview moi je
veux faire 100 kg d'ici un deux ans pour
être drafté on la réalité des choses
c'est qu'il est toujours à 88 kg et
qu'il a pas vraiment beaucoup pris
malgré les poulets légaux et du coup il
pour l'instant il trouve un autre moyen
de de faire son scoring et d'être
efficace
jus pardon est-ce que est-ce que tu vois
d'autres choses qui pourraient le faire
rentrer en NBA au-delà de du shotmaking
comme comme disait Hugues est-ce que
est-ce que sur le shooting toi tu es
aussi confiant parce qu'il y a une
diversité ou est-ce que il y a aussi des
des points je sais pas défensifs ou dans
la création qui te laissent espérer
quelque chose de bien
alors c'est compliqué peut-être qu'on en
parlera après
moi j'aime bien le son côté driven kick
vraiment il a il le fait il a fait
régulièrement toute l'année même si les
chiffres sont pas sont pas fous et 16%
d'assistes c'est pas mal c'est c'est il
y a des joueurs et des spécialistes qui
du shoot qui sont à bien moins en NCA
qui se font drafté
entre finir au cercle et faire la passe
donc ça c'est pas un trou noir quoi
non ouais non parce que c'est par série
quoi voilà
il s'est passé ok qu'est-ce que tu vois
développer du coup les points qui
pourraient justement ralentir qui
pourrait rebuter certaines équipes ou
quand une fois qu'il est drafté faire
qui qu'il a du mal à obtenir du temps de
jeu quoi pour moi c'est la défense c'est
clairement la défense et l'intensité
qu'il a montré toute l'année
c'est très difficile à dire je trouve
en fait c'est le point d'interrogation
je me suis posé c'est je pense que il
pourrait parce que il a la longueur de
bras comme il dit qu'il a des capacités
physiques enfin athlétique suffisante
après il montre pas il montre aucune
souvent et montre très peu de volonté on
va dire ça comme ça et puis parfois
c'est on peut se poser la question de la
compréhension quoi quand il est au vol
c'est parfois c'est ridicule quoi il
regarde le ballon il attend peut-être
que je suis un peu caricatural mais de
ce côté là c'est c'est un petit peu
inquiétant alors la question que je me
pose c'est est-ce que c'est une
dynamique de groupe est-ce que c'est
c'est un gros pas très discipliné
c'était une équipe pas très disciplinée
[Musique]
il y a deux trucs c'est là est-ce qu'il
peut prendre de la masse ce joueur parce
qu'il montrait qu'il voulait en prendre
et que pour l'instant il explose sur le
contact dans le sur le sur le premier
impact défensif est-ce qu'il va réussir
en haut du corps à ACP cire et puis
deuxièmement il y a cette main gauche il
change bien de moi il change bien de
direction mais il faut que tout soit
initié main gauche et quand tu
l'orientes dans ce côté-là
enfin si tu lui empêche d'aller de ce
côté-là bah il y a plus grand chose qui
reste sur Marcel et Maxwell Lewis et
c'est souvent là qu'il en échec et même
au tir
une équipe qui va vouloir un shooter on
est un sur un mec qui est très comment
dire latéralisé c'est que côté droit
lorsque la balle arrive sur sa main
gauche donc ma faible il va pouvoir
déclencher en première attention il a 40
%, ça a quasiment 46 % d'efficacité
lorsque la balade ça m'inforte il double
son volume de tir mais il est à 29%
d'efficacité alors toujours en prenant
des step backs etc mais c'est que il y a
un vrai scouting report qui va être fait
sur ce joueur je pense par des
professionnels assez rapidement et
si il évolue pas rapidement il va pas
être en efficacité et jouera pas
il y a un problème mécanique à ça
est-ce que tu vois un problème mécanique
est-ce que vu que quand la balle arrive
de la gauche il est précis ça veut dire
que son pied fort et son pied droit et
que du coup il est pied droit main
droite et que ça pose des problèmes je
pense surtout qu'il réfléchit pas parce
que quand la balle elle arrive sur les
mains droite il sait qu'il peut pas
partir en dribble donc il va vite axer
et tirer tu vois et comme en plus la
défense veut pas qu'il parte en dribble
et bah en fait il a pas trop d'autres
choix donc il tire et il réfléchit pas
et peut-être qu'il prend plus de catch
and shoot et moi de step back ont testé
et est-ce que est-ce que toi tu
mentalement comment tu t'es value ce
joueur est-ce que tu vois dans
l'attitude et peut-être dans ce qu'il
dit je sais pas si tu as vu des
interviews ou quoi non j'ai pas vu
d'interview mais
le body language de pas très bon cette
année il est pas très bon c'est le
leader de l'équipe
d'une équipe qui est catastrophique
comme a dit Hugues c'est il baisse
souvent les bras quand ils sentent le
match échappe il sait pas c'est pas un
gagnant en fait il a pas montré des
envies de gagner le match et ni côté
attaque ni côté défense quoi donc ça
c'est je pense que c'est assez gênant en
fait dans à voir et
c'est pas très bon au niveau du mindset
il est pas il est pas à fond quoi
dans un autre contexte que qu'est-ce qui
peut donner un contexte plus comme tu
l'as dit où on le on le challenge je
vous demande positif
comment tu tu vois son utilisation en
année 1 en NBA est-ce que ça va être
planté dans le corner ou est-ce qu'on
peut le faire courir autour d'écran sur
qui va défendre ce genre de choses
alors
par rapport à ce que disait moi j'ai
trouvé un j'ai trouvé une stats 40% en
4e shooter donc il sait le faire il sait
le faire et il pourrait le faire après
c'est pas son c'est pas son comment dire
son jeu quoi mais
en fait moi ce qui me gêne dans un
projection c'est c'est sa défense en
fait je sais pas si je sais pas si c'est
ta question mais
toi tu penses que ça va le freiner quoi
pour rester sur le sur le terrain il va
falloir qu'ils défendent plus dur plus
plus intensément et plus régulièrement
Hugues est-ce qu'on a des joueurs de ce
profil qu'on qu'on réussit en NBA ça
c'est ma question pour pour toi pendant
que je demande à Jules
ce qui ça te laisse du temps pour
réfléchir mon Hugues
parce que j'étais en train de regarder
deux joueurs précisément sur donc on
s'est rejoint au jardin un bon leader on
s'est connecté je qu'est-ce qu'on peut
espérer pour
Maxwell Lewis dans quelques années en
fait est-ce que est-ce que il peut
devenir un mec qui drive un peu est-ce
que voilà quel quels évolutions eu
parlaient du poids est-ce qu'il y en a
est-ce que tu envoies d'autres
si tu cliques si on il montre qu'il
s'est défendent s'il développe sa main
ça m'a un faible
ça peut être un joueur de bon très
intéressant
de poids il a tous les outils enfin il
est à la taille il a le gabarit et le
shoot quoi donc s'il soit deux choses
importantes
comme ça
Malik
moniquement que bonne scie qui défendait
pas trop assez fin compliqué dans les
premières années et qui fait un truc
bien sacrémento qui est devenu vraiment
un beau catch and shooter et l'athlète
vraiment très délié j'aime bien c'est un
sacré athlète on est sur le même niveau
d'athlète non mais on est sur le côté tu
vois fin qui monte délier et en moins
athlétique j'aime bien tu vois Jordan
pool qui était par actuellement très à
la mode et qui était un peu considéré
comme un scorer qui réfléchissait pas
forcément qui était pas dans le body
langage qui est défendait pas un peu fou
auquel moi je croyais pas tant que ça et
dans un contexte idyllique pour lui il a
réussi à devenir plus complet et puis
pour terminer
un gars au début on trouvait qu'il
défendait pas pas de bonne mentalité
devine booker qui s'est épaissi et qui a
mis beaucoup de temps et c'est vraiment
des scénarios idéaux que je donne mais
genre de gala qui ont réussi à marcher
pieds à plein d'autres qui ont pas passé
le cap hein par exemple qui est pas fini
c'est un très jeune joueur encore mais
un côté monté fin athlétique beaucoup de
tirs et après défensivement un peu léger
et très latéralisé au niveau du drive
dans la main et qui fonctionne pas c'est
un mauvais mauvais exemple les points
communs des joueurs que tu as cité qui
ont réussi c'est quand même des des
joueurs qui étaient un gros fac très
grosse machine et qui même si on les a
mal utilisés avec
fort potentiel voir avait montré
d'autres choses au lycée
juste avec d'autres noms c'était
beaucoup plus sombre
j'imagine j'ai trouvé Hugues hyper
positif sur ses comparaisons mais
c'était il lui faut un développement à
la pour atteindre son potentiel c'est
plus comme ça qu'il fallait le
l'entendre
tu vois comme Johnson ou
s'il a défense vient pas genre Duncan
Robinson tu vois des grands shooters des
shooters de grande taille
il faut quand même du développement pour
arriver à ça
je te confirme que faut
il faut être un monstre d'appui quoi le
gars
d'endurance et d'appui ça peut être
intéressant effectivement
est-ce que vous y croyez l'un l'autre on
termine par ça
moi j'avoue j'y crois pas trop alors
c'est mal parce que j'aime bien mais j'y
crois pas trop parce que
je vois des tels carences que
avec comment dire la petite expérience
que que j'ai je me dis que je sais pas
s'il peut passer le cap l'année dernière
on avait parlé de on parlait de de
Mathurin qui montrait pas sa défense
mais c'était c'était autre chose quoi
mais tu croyait mature
parce que pour d'autres raisons quoi là
je suis parti ouais là tu
Hugues vas-y est-ce qu'il y a aussi un
truc de
tu la décris très rapidement comme un
kiffeur alors c'était pour la vanne mais
il y a un peu un côté il faut un peu un
mental de tueur pour passer le cap
possible ouais c'est ça je le vois pas
trop mal alors je le connais je le
connais pas je vois pas l'entraînement
c'est sûr mais je
moi j'y crois pas parce que je pense
qu'il y a des joueurs qui font dans ce
qu'on attendra de lui il y a des gens
qui le feront bien mieux et que je ne
sais pas si on va lui laisser le temps
d'être ce qu'il veut être encore une
fois je sais pas s'il va réussir à
montrer assez pour moi il a c'est un
jour tu vas faire pas mal de jilig et
qui va faire des hommes carton et jelly
et je sais pas s'il va réussir un jour à
pouvoir faire la même chose en NBA donc
je miserai pas dessus peut-être que ça
change serait de se faire drafter par
une équipe un peu toute pourrie et qu'il
est une garbage saison une garbage fin
de saison et qui prennent confiance quoi
ah ouais c'est sûr que on l'a vu les
dernières années mais quand tu es un
gros talent et que tu te fais de rater
par une équipe très compétitive et que
tu joues pas bah tu disparais très vite
quand on pense à des pitchs Boston et
Ken Johnson qui ont commencé et deux en
gros potentiels qui ont commencé au
Clipper ce qui avait kowaylord et PJ
actuellement on en parle plus quoi enfin
c'est des c'est dégâts dont la carrière
dans le train déjà quasiment passé alors
qu'ils sont là depuis que trois ans
seulement
donc on peut lui souhaiter un premier
tour peut-être pourquoi pas dans ou
alors un contrat de seconde tour solide
comme on le voit de plus en plus ces
dernières années en début de seconde
tour
et bien messieurs merci beaucoup on
souhaite beaucoup de poulet de gaufres
et de la réussite à Maxwell Lewis
c'était l'essentiel sur lui vous pouvez
retrouver sa fiche sur envergure.co et
tout nos autres podcasts sur toutes les
plateformes d'écoute notamment notre
série de podcasts de cette année
consacrée à Victor one byama ciao tout
le monde